so I'm up to devins what do I want from
world leaders at Davos well I think
first of all getting this issue on
people's agendas is so important we need
to break the taboo we need to move FGM
out of the silent margins where it's
been and really into the mainstream I
want everyone who's working on women
empowerment of girls education to ensure
that FGM is on their agenda I want
people to realize the enormity of what's
happening to three million girls in here
I want people to believe that this is
our problem it's not just happening
elsewhere it's happening within our
communities and we are a global
community things like this shouldn't be
oh it's Africa oh it's indonesia oh it's
Islam it's not it's down to all of us to
play a part in this i want to see if we
can coalesce and get more funding and
more resources to this issue yes times
are tough and there are humanitarian
disasters everything in the globe that's
happening and yet still when I go to
sleep every night I can still hear that
little
and what she's saying is why won't
people help me I want to make sure that
we can all wake up and say that we've
done what we can and no one more the
global leaders who are taking us through
who are steering our planet into the
next decade I want them to be thinking
we can do something about this this
shouldn't happen on our watch let's wake
up and let end FGM now
you